[Music]
one thing everyone's been talking about
today is and I mentioned it up front top
of the show John Travolta's embarrassing
mistake at last night's Oscars he was
supposed to introduce singer idina
menzel okay but here's what he said
instead please welcome the wickedly
talented one and only together does he
that's right instead of saying idina
menzel he said adele dazeem now this is
very embarrassing for John Travolta but
it's actually been great publicity for
this lady please welcome aspiring singer
adele dazeem
hi there Adele hi conan this is all so
exciting before last night no one even
knew who I was but now no one will
forever forget my name
get that Shazam because that's Shazam no
isn't your name adele dazeem
oh god yes it is this is so embarrassing
well maybe for you but it's great news
for this other singer please welcome
give that Shazam
hi Cornyn hi Gazette yes must be very
exciting for you it is after this
everyone's going to be googling my name
gizelle Kazu wait that's not my name
no no you're right but it's this
singer's name please welcome gizelle
kazoo
[Applause]
[Applause]
to all of you ladies thank you